what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so bottom line extremists I was I
was in kind of a weird spot honestly I'm
really just kind of experimenting on you
guys I'm experimenting in so far that I
am curious how you guys respond to
covering older videos instead of all-new
all-different marvel until like August
or September so when like Marvel legacy
drops versus how you guys respond to
covering all-new all-different mobile
stuff I mean it'll be a few things here
and there we cover like old man Logan
and Ultimates and stuff like that but
because it takes six months to finish a
story you know I was like well we can
kind of cover some older stuff in
between so I'm just kind of curious how
you guys respond to that whole thing but
as I was thinking about that there were
two different wraps that we could have
taken with Iron Man we could have
covered Iron Man vol 4 or we could have
covered Iron Man vol 5 4 is longer than
5 in 5 of course you know being newer is
more modern and really kind of ties into
a lot of what people are talking about
in terms of what's going on with Iron
Man right now and so I figured we kind
of do 5 since we could probably get
about 6 or 7 videos out of it and then
call it a day and that'll really give me
a good litmus test and how you guys
respond to things so by the time this
was all said and done you guys make it
clear that you just don't care about
older stuff and you want all-new
all-different marvel then we'll switch
back to that we may be able to find a
happy balance with both but with regards
to this one one of the reasons that I
chose that is because with extrem it's
fresh on our minds this one deals
directly with the fallout of that but
there are a couple things to run over
specifically with vol 4 nothing super
complicated nothing really difficult or
convoluted with the character of Maya
Hansen for example she was basically
arrested at the end of the extremis
storyline in volume 4 released on parole
and then she went to go work for shield
and Tony Stark because at the time Tony
Stark was director of shield following
the events of civil war and so because
of that it was really just kind of her
approving the fact that she was more or
less reformed the whole idea with
extremis was just kind of part of her
past and she was ready to let that go
and it was really an I mean it was just
kind of a way to you know build her
character a bit the other half of this
is that in the post Civil War landscape
Iron Man vol 4 stretched through a lot
of things and went all the way up to
like siege and so on and so forth what
ended up happening is going into siege
and really even after the events of
Civil War when Tony Stark's moral
compass was called into question the
idea that maybe he had been fighting on
the wrong side for all the wrong reasons
he more or less kind of suffered this
crisis of conscience so after being
ousted as director of shield he
basically formed a company called stark
resilient
which basically serve the purpose of
being like a more economic friendly arm
where Sark International was more of
like a weapons manufacturing arm of
stark resilient was going to focus more
on the everyday thing so just improving
technology overall for the betterment of
society itself the issue with this is
that it made him a target for a multiple
you know multitude of different people
you know injure those that he cared
about pepper pasta so on and so forth
and so Tony Stark actually left
resilient and made Pepper Potts the CEO
so those are guys who are who are
reading like superior Iron Men that's
where that came from
volume 4 has some cool things here and
there but I think the volume 5 is more
pertinent to just cool Iron Man stuff
now this particular story arc is called
believed and what this does is deal with
the fallout of extremis and it tells us
that extremists did not go away this
experience is very much there now what
we do here is we actually pick up in
buoyance Aires Argentina with Maya
Hansen now the crazy thing about this is
that she's being pursued by aim advanced
idea mechanics now here's the thing
advanced idea mechanics originally
started out as like the science /
technology arm of Hydra with the goal of
world domination
eventually aim broke away from Hydra
following the death of Baron von
Strucker and became their own
organization but they still have the
same goal of like dominating the world
but for example advanced idea mechanics
were the first ones to create a cosmic
cube and so again they have all kinds of
different you know studies and so on but
extremis is just another instance of
them trying to launch a plot that will
see them you know trying to secure world
domination and so the result of this is
that by Hansen inner panic sends out an
automated message Tony Stark gets it and
basically it's her saying look you know
this is an automated message informing
you that if you get this I'm likely dead
and extremis is on the loose again now
this is kind of cool because the first
place we go to is basically one group
this managed to take hold of extremis
and this is basically just an
organization that's more or less
advanced idea mechanics of themselves
now of course the cool thing about this
is that a lot of what we end up seeing
here you know in this conflict between
Tony Stark the faculty basically has
armor that's in a liquid state this all
really kind of lays the groundwork for
like into sim armor for example that he
has is superior Iron Man different
things like that and that's why I said
volume 5 is a little more pertinent in
terms of Iron Man and as far as you guys
think of them because of the fact
there's so many interesting things in
here that laid the groundwork for what
comes later of course really all
stuff you know indocin the whole nine
yards that whole predecessor was
extremists the fact your name's here
that Tony Stark basically locating
finding and getting a hold of their head
guys was really quick and it was really
simple I mean aim was purporting that
extremists would be like the next stage
and technology or something along those
lines and the idea was to basically use
it for their own ends now of course the
question that twenty start has is where
is the rest of extremis what's going on
here now eventually he manages to find
himself mixed up with some of the guise
of advanced idea mechanics who have
reached beyond and actually have a place
called new Avalon now Tony Stark himself
as Iron Man has intrigued quite a few
people and this particular instance is
really more like a battle it's more of
like a conflict what these guys have
done is they have taken an extremist
they've made it into actual armors and
then brought in basically people who
specialize in a multitude of different
things whether it's hand-to-hand combat
being a pilot whatever the case may be
and the idea here is to run a gauntlet
can may be as good as Tony Stark because
keep in mind in the realm of Marvel
Comics when it comes to like mechanized
suits or technology or something like
that
Tony Stark is the number one guy in
terms of weaponizing technology now in
terms of overall intelligence it's kind
of a toss-up I mean an all-new
all-different marvel they established
that moon girls like the smartest girl
on the planet but prior to that it was
like Reed Richards Valeri Richards and
Doctor Doom who held the number one spot
and now who it was it was actually
number one would change based on the
story where those three were generally
the smartest people on planet in terms
of weaponizing technology Tony Stark is
the number one guy and the Iron Man suit
is the title to beat if these guys these
pilots in these extremities can beat
Iron Man that it means that this weapon
is a success that extremists as has been
used by this organization will
effectively work they can in turn build
more suits hand those over and be can't
you know gain new contracts with the US
government to really replace what it is
that Tony Stark does now the cool thing
about all this is that it basically
creates a scenario whereby time and
himself is basically able to function at
peak capacity and what I mean by this is
Tony Stark's armors are usually modular
whenever it comes to like you know the
different equipment and somebody uses
and what that means is that different
aspects of the suit can be detached and
something else can be put in its place
and that's really the nature of it here
is an invitation to use all the tools at
his disposal and see if they can face
off against each one of these individual
guys and for the most part he's
successful he met
to stave off the attack of almost every
single one of these guys the goal is
that if he wins he ultimately gets to
take the extremists with him and so the
cool thing about this is that some of
these guys specialize in hand-to-hand
combat and the suits reflect that
accordingly in the sense of they're
really more kind of internally start
space punching kicking so on and so
forth others are better at flight and
diverting attacks play more defensively
it was really kind of cool to see how
these armors relate to what it is that
Iron Man has but at the end of the day
they are not Tony Stark they do not have
the ability to capitalize on their own
skills in the same capacity the 20 sock
has the ability to capitalize on his and
so of course finding these guys really
serves as a distraction and what he
basically does it just kind of snatch up
the extremis kit and then just take off
I mean really the most dishonorable way
in the conflict to just kind of grab the
thing and then just bolt and that's
really it I mean it's kind of it's kind
of a crappy thing to do but what this is
designed to do is basically give us a
tour of how extremists can be used in
different ways this next guy actually
uses it for medical purposes and it's
really kind of cool again because of the
fact that Maya had said Tony Stark a
notification saying hey look here are
the versions of extremis that have
managed to get out here are their you
know unique identity signatures it's
basically just tracking down these
different locations traveling to those
locations and facing off against people
the other half of this is we actually
get to see a little bit of expansion on
the various suits that Tony Stark uses
for example one of these suits is one
where he basically has the ability of
camouflage where he can bend light
around himself now if you're interested
in the different suits that Tony Stark
uses I have like four or five videos
that I did we basically run over each
one of his suits and what it is that
they're capable of doing again this one
in particular is one that we had
referenced previously where he's able to
basically bend light around himself to
either make him invisible or to
camouflage himself and create Holograms
but once he ends up getting into this
particular building where this extremist
kid is being located at and he gets down
to the basement he actually finds a girl
in bed but it also comes across some
members of its rogues gallery now this
is also kind of cool because it shows us
some of the other ways that extremists
can be used not in the sense of creating
suits of armor but in the sense of
enhancing people's already existing
abilities the living laser firebrand
vibro these are guys that have their own
intrinsic capabilities and powers for
example firebrand manipulates fire under
normal circumstances she's no real
threat to Tony Stark
with extremist enhancements her powers
are pushed that much further not only
that because designed to enhance the
human body for physical agility her
strength so on and so forth all these
things are increased now again Tony
Stark is coming out of all of this
having dealt with extremists before and
so it's not like he's taken by surprise
the same way he was with now and instead
all of his suits were upgraded to be
able to withstand virtually any scenario
when it comes to the extremist tech go
sit down and he'll encounter a situation
that he's never met before
he'll overcome his situation and then
he'll sit down and say okay under what
circumstances could I could I encounter
this scenario again what million ways
could this scenario play out and then
every last one of his seats will be
upgraded to meet that particular
scenario in this instance because of the
fact this is Rob's gallery he spot all
these different guys time and time again
his suits are already equipped for the
most part to be able to handle that and
true if you know these guys are taken
out pretty easily I mean they're
defeated pretty readily but of course
with a living laser having charged
through a wall what this does is it
tells Tony Stark they've probably
charged through multiple walls meaning
that just following the holes in the
wall is basically what it is but the
fact remains that once he gets inside
this room this is an instance where not
everybody who catches extremists uses it
for nefarious ends and this particular
guy that has a daughter that's basically
dying of cancer and the idea was to use
experiments for the purpose of trying to
find a way to cure her the issue here is
that this guy does not know the ins and
out of extremists he's smart but he
doesn't quite know how to use it or how
to modify it in a way that will benefit
his daughter and so what he did is he
actually kidnapped several people are
used several people and injected them
with extremists hoping that he'd be able
to find a way to basically cure his
daughter
the issue is that you know for the first
person it didn't matter they effectively
ended up dying for the second person
they were cured but his daughter is
extremely sick in the same capacity as
the first person and so really you know
what seems to be the case that there's
no way for his daughter to be rescued in
comes Tori start with an inoculation
that's basically going to cure this
guy's daughter but the problem with this
is that this guy broke the law
despite his desperation despite the fact
that he wanted to keep his daughter safe
at the end of the day he still broke the
law and so the result of this is that
he's basically going to be arrested and
taken to jail but his daughter is going
to live so again it's kind of a cool
scenario to see how Tony Stark deals
with these different versions of the
extremis virus now from here we switch
over to the catechol
homes in Paris if you got to bring a
chance you should definitely look it up
there are people who will like party
like they'll go and don't have parties
and stuff like that and they'll go into
the catacombs especially like if they're
not from France they'll get lost and
they'll die they'll starve to death
because it is a labyrinth down there
it's absolutely insane with regards to
this whole thing in Paris Tony Sarg of
course realizes that one of the signals
is coming from the catacombs now the
catacombs themselves are a small tight
space which means there's no real room
for maneuverability and so Tony Stark
plans accordingly and basically adopts
one of the newest versions of the
Hulkbuster armor now this is a hope
buster slash a general tank all purpose
suit in the sense that it's not designed
explicitly for the Hulk but it certainly
can help so once he gets down there what
he finds is a veritable blood bag I mean
it's absolutely insane there's just body
parts just pieces of scientists all over
the place so of course this leads him to
coming across something like twelve or
thirteen women who have these different
edgings carved on their faces now this
is when things get kind of weird and
intrude it's played pretty fast and
loose I mean the idea from one of the
scientists seems to be that they were
trying to resurrect a great black
infinite we're not told what that is
honestly it doesn't matter it's really
just kind of hearing Gillan saying these
are crazy religious fanatics you know
and as a result they ended up just
creating monsters with no understanding
of what it wasn't they were doing but
just tells us that basically when
extremists when Maya Hansen was forced
to recreate it by aim and it was sold by
aim it was pay man whoever wants to buy
can have it we don't care what you do
with it and so again it's really kind of
wild here just because of the fact that
one of the scientists has left tries to
take out Tony Stark of course he fails
but in doing so where this scientist had
all these different you know edgings and
stuff around the door in order to keep
himself protected with the door
destroyed the protection is no longer
there this guy's basically just kind of
torn to pieces now this is when we get
into one of the darker sides of Tony
Stark and the reason why is because of
the fact that of course he has his new
AI essentially replicate the symbols
that were previously on the door to
create a kind of you know protective or
around himself after which you know all
these different young women just kind of
enter a pacified state but because of
the fact that extremists if allowed to
manifest for too long basically corrupts
and destroys the minds of the people who
have ingested it what it basically means
is that there's no saving these girls
they're too far gone in truth all Tony
Stark can really do is just issue a
mercy killing and that's exactly what he
does he basically just begins using a
high intensity laser
- incinerate these girls heads now this
is dark but it's also as humane as 20
star can possibly be they don't feel a
thing I mean one minute there's a bright
light the next that's it that's all she
wrote and so it takes 20 seconds for it
to charge which means that if he's
issuing out 11 or 12 shots he's got to
wait a little over 2 minutes in order to
basically take out all these different
folks so because of that it's pretty
intense and it takes a toll because for
him he's basically killing people and if
at all possible Tony Stark always tries
to keep people alive unless there's
absolutely no choice and in this
instance there was really no choice and
so what is it happening is this last
little extremist kid actually takes us
into space and it's really kind of cool
the way that this happens just because
the fact that one of the people or at
least really one of the guys you know
that is taking this was a guy named Eli
now of course Eli in 20 start go back
quite a bit in the sense that they've
been both you know comrades and they've
you know been soldiers at arm so to
speak on the front line of the
technological arms race and different
things like that but Eli is actually
using extremists for a pretty
interesting concept historically
speaking extremis has always been
weaponized ever since the virus was
created and released people have always
weaponized it now I mean in this
instance we see a people who are trying
to use it for medical means but nine
times out of ten is being used in some
form of weaponry what this guy Li wants
to do is actually use it for the purpose
of exploration in his mind humanity is
limited on the planet Earth we talked
about this when Ironman joined the
guardians of the galaxy and actually the
way the story ends will go directly into
guardians of the galaxy so I might put
it in that playlist just for the sake of
it but the fact remains here that with
regards to Humanity on earth Humanity is
very primitive relatively speaking -
like all the other species I mean you
got to think the Kree Empire stretches
systems solar systems the scroll Empire
is the exact same way the Shiar Empire
is an amalgamation of different races
and here you have humanity stuck on a
singular planet this guy using extremis
is to basically say why be limited by
such a basic thing why would you want to
weaponize extremis let me use it for
exploration and so the goal is to
reprogram extremists so that it can be
modified in the human genome to allow
people to walk on Mars without suits and
basically begin the process of
colonizing other planets looking to the
future now under normal circumstances
Tony Stark would agree
and in fact he says that he says look I
would agree with you I'd be I'd be
behind you 100% of the way under any
normal circumstance if this was
sanctioned by the federal government if
like Reed Richards had a hand in it or
something like that but if I can come in
here then that means dr. doom can come
in here it means that like magneto could
come in here I mean any number of
villains could just walk in and pick it
and then suddenly they just got a
ridiculous amount of power what this
does is it leads to the most logical
outcome a conflict between Tony Stark
and you know Eli and its various forces
now of course again this is Tony Stark
playing is smart it's him sitting down
and saying look we're in a space station
out in the middle of nowhere they're not
going to shoot bullets just because of
the fact that they did all the way take
is a pinprick of a hole in a wall and
then suddenly it's just explosive
decompression oxygen just goes violently
escaping out of the hole next thing you
know the whole old station blows up and
it takes all of us with them and so in
his mind he knew that they were simply
going to go for incapacitating him well
because of the fact that he's wearing a
mechanized suit they were use
electronics and so as a result he
basically reconfigures a suit to cope
with any kind of electromagnetic
interference which allows them to
maintain this functionality and then in
turn take all these different guys out
after which he grabs the extremists kit
and takes off and so what is up
happening here is Tony Stark goes back
and has a conversation with Pepper Potts
so it's really kind of cool to see this
because he says look after Civil War you
know after Secret Invasion after being
director of shield being forced out of
shield after starting resilient than
having to leave resilient after faking
my death after all these things that
have happened I'm ready to take a break
like I'm ready to clear my head I'm
tired of being honored I'm ready to go
out I'm ready to do something else I'm
ready to go experience something else do
any number of things and so what he does
is he basically donned the suit
specialized for interstellar travel for
traveling the space way and he
essentially just leaves the planet er he
basically just takes off and as a result
this is when he joins the guardians of
the galaxy but with that being said guys
if you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys should the sub line
to become part of the lab for the guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys on
it pieces
[Music]